[Music]
chapter one he adored Las Vegas a city
that looked as beautiful as him no no no
no that's too narcissistic let me start
this over to him Las Vegas was a city
full of color energy and opportunity a
complete contrast from where he came
from
this is the story of how Daniel pol
escaped the clutches of the iron curtain
on its zip line and won his freedom
yeah this sounds much better
[Music]
hold on let's pause for a second to
understand this story we need to go back
like way back like back to the 80s
the place is Czechoslovakia the ruling
party communists our character is Daniel
pol a young man who was politically
outspoken people that knew me really
well they told me hey listen all I can
tell you is you really want to tone it
down Tommy a political speech because uh
you wind up in prison and that's when I
started plotting escape while planning
his exit strategy Daniel met another
radical thinker a physicist named Robert
Oz WA
Robert was pretty well gifted when it
came to physics he was imprisoned for
political reasons so I knew that this
guy's crazy enough to be my partner in
crime to get out with we tried to come
up with all kinds of crazy ideas like
building our own rockets and flying over
the Iron Curtain digging tunnels none of
it seemed viable for many reasons then
one day Leslie Robert a glancing in a
power line and something told me you
should be worried he says we're gonna
zipline into Austria I said no do you
clinically insane and he says and that's
why we're gonna get out so the two got
to work and over the next several months
they built and tested their own police
the plan was to infiltrate the border
zone climb up the tower set up the
police zipline over the Iron Curtain
climb down from the next power into
no-man's land and then make it into
Austria the reason why this was so
insanely dangerous because we could have
gotten shot at the border could have
gotten electrocuted could have gotten
torn apart by border dogs and then you
have 380 thousand volts coursing
underneath your feet yeah this mission
was to put it mildly extremely dangerous
it was almost like a mission impossible
but that didn't stop these two with
their pulleys made and their plan in
place they headed out and climbed the
tower Robert one first and when he took
off my heart just sunk and I was like
yeah there is no turning back I am doing
this I just
I decided to go for it I went for it
when I was applying it was like mixture
emotions you never experienced before
you are way up high you have a lot of
electricity around you that was crazy
but they sparked all the close calls we
made it Daniel and Robert became local
celebrities appearing in news outlets
all over Europe Daniel even donated his
pulley to the Checkpoint Charlie Museum
in Berlin the pulley still hangs there
today
Robert remained in Austria but Daniel
his sights were on America so he moved
to the one place that could match his
personality Vegas so wrote a book I got
married draw the cab in Vegas I don't
think I would rather cab anywhere else
but in Vegas it's fun very international
City very dynamic it's awesome I want it
to be free at the park yes I wanted to
piss all the comics I wanted to show
them that doesn't matter what are in
curtain what wall they're gonna build
how many Border Patrol guards they're
gonna place on the border I'm still
getting through they cannot defeat the
human spirit that wants it
[Music]